Alex, Kevin, congratulations.
You guys are in the
third and final round
of this competition, which
means that you're both one
step closer to the title
of Forged in Fire Champion
and a check for $10,000.
All you need to
do now is go home
and recreate this iconic
weapon from history--
the spatha.
Good luck, bladesmiths.
We'll see you in four days.
Good luck.
Kevin.
So it's day one in
Belleville, West Virginia.
I've got a spatha to go make.
Let's get crack-a-lacking.
Woo!
I'm gonna be using 51-60.
It's a forgiving medium.
It'll bring some strength
to whatever they're
gonna smash, cut, break, kill.
So I'm gonna try Big
Sexy first to bash down
the width of that
material to about two
and a half, two and a
quarter inches wide.
Come on, dang it.
Work.
Four days isn't enough
time to make a spatha.
You don't know what the
complications are gonna be.
She's getting there, though.
I slowly started drawing it out.
I'm about 35 inches long.
You know, it's just
patience, getting
the equipment to work right.
Tomorrow, pressure
will be on, because I
gotta get this thing quenched.
If I don't, I'm behind the ball.
Woo!
Definitely excited to be
back home, back in my shop,
where I'm nice and comfortable.
I'm gonna do a full Damascus
blade with a little bit
of a ladder pattern in it.
I'm really looking
forward to going all out
and making something really
cool to impress the judges.
First press was just nice
and quick and light, just
to push everything together.
This next press will be
a little more aggressive.
Probably the most important
part of this entire weld.
My weld seemed to have
stuck pretty well.
I'm gonna start
drawing this thing out.
I've got one seam
that came apart.
I think if I just flux it, get
it hot, and press it again,
should be OK.
Let's hope.
This might be a make-or-break
moment right here.
I really hope
that's the only one,
but deep down, I'm
petrified that there
is gonna be more of
these seams opening
up throughout this billet.
As I go to start
drawing this billet out,
a big seam just opens up right
in the center of my billet.
So I think my best
bet is gonna be
to break this billet in half,
salvage as much welded steel
as I possibly can.
And I'll just do a generic
random pattern Damascus.
But it'll still be
a Damascus sword.
Well, the good news is both
of those seem really solid.
So at least we got
something out of that.
KEVIN (VOICEOVER):
Today, I need to get
the blade done and quenched.
So I got the shoulders put in.
I have the medial ridge, where
you can distinctly see where
it's starting to come together.
It's time for the quench.
Ah, [bleep].
Look at that [bleep] end.
We're quenching again, because
I don't have time to eff
around with the normalization.
Because I went all the way down
to the bottom, and I felt it
bend.
I got to go through all
the steps all over again.
Still got that bend.
I'm gonna temper overnight.
And in that process, it'll start
to, hopefully, normalize down.
It's hit or miss.
It's either gonna go well,
or it's gonna go wrong.
And, yeah, it went wrong today.
ALEX (VOICEOVER): It's
the morning of day two.
Definitely got some
setbacks yesterday.
Starting the day with
my billet tacked up
and ready for forge welding.
And hoping to end the day with
a quenched and hardened spatha.
First press.
Looks OK so far.
But I'm still gonna
be really careful.
I've got my billet drawn
out pretty close to shape.
I have just enough length there.
You can see, I'm kind of forging
in that medial ridge already.
This is the longest blade I
have ever attempted to quench.
I pull the blade out of the
oil at the end of the day.
I have an intact Damascus blade.
First thing tomorrow,
I'm gonna get
my blade etched and
the handle prepared
and looking forward
to a good day.
I'm feeling better
than last night,
because I got the blade
tempered and got it straight.
Still behind the ball.
I'm gonna start to
fit up the handle,
start looking at different parts
to what I think looks well.
So my design plan
for this pommel
is I'm gonna take two
ends of the deer antler,
and I'm going to carve a
lion's head out of them.
Hand-carving anything
is time-consuming,
so I can't get lost in my head.
I'll set it in on top of
glow in the dark resin.
And then I'll fill that
in with a clear epoxy.
I'm not walking in there
with something plain.
Tomorrow, I'm gonna
put some bronze medal
stain on the blade.
And I'm gonna finish
this no matter what.
It'll be done.
ALEX (VOICEOVER):
Start of day four.
Fatigue of the
past couple days is
definitely starting to set in.
The blade's been etched
in the coffee overnight
to really bring
out the contrast.
Yeah, it really
darkened up that 10-84.
So the spatha needs
to have a wooden guard
and a disk shaped pommel.
So I'm going to do
a stacked handle.
I'm using iron wood for
the guard and the pommel,
because it's super strong.
And then I'm gonna use
blackwood for the main part
of the handle.
I've got all my individual
pieces of this handle.
Fit it up nice and tight.
Got to get this blade sharpened.
I've never sharpened
anything this long before,
but I know how to put
an edge on a knife.
I cannot wait to see this
thing put to the test.
Word.
All right, bladesmiths, your
spatha swords look amazing.
But it's time to find out
what kind of lethal damage
that they can do.
To do that, I will
take your weapon,
deliver some killing slashes
and blows on this more
than willing ballistics dummy.
Alex, you're up first.
You ready for this?
Let's do it.
[blade impacts]
All right, Alex,
first up, I can really
appreciate the beauty that you
have with your Damascus pattern
right there.
It really stands out.
Very clean lines.
The medial ridge
you have on here,
I can imagine how
much work that takes
to get it almost perfectly
straight all the way
through to the tip.
Your tip is sharp enough
to penetrate with a thrust
and lacerate on the way out.
And most importantly,
it will kill.
Thank you.
Good job.
All right, Kevin,
it's your turn.
So are you ready?
Hell yeah.
Let's do this.
Alex's spatha just destroyed
that ballistics dummy.
And now, I'm feeling
anxious, excited.
I got the adrenaline going.
- There's no medial ridge.
- Let me see.
What's up?
No medial ridge on
either side of the blade?
That's one of the parameters.
Right?
Kevin, your blade must
fall within our parameters
in order to be tested evenly and
fairly with your competitors.
Your blade does not
have a central ridge.
That was a parameter
that was outlined
before we ever sent you home.
And for that reason, you cannot
be the Forged in Fire Champion.
Come on, my friend.
You know, it's just a
bummer I can't see it tested.
That's what I really
wanted to see.
I want to see how it holds up.
Nice work on that handle.
Thank you.
I appreciate it.
When I was making it, it
had the defined ridge in it.
Just with the
sanding and grinding,
it just took more of it off.
But this whole experience
has been a blast.
Congratulations.
KEVIN (VOICEOVER):
This isn't a loss.
I'm coming home with
a $10,000 experience.
Alex, you made a
sharp and deadly spatha,
but not only that,
you made something
that is detailed and beautiful.
Your attention to detail has
elevated you to the title
of Forged in Fire Champion.
Congratulations.
Your title comes with
a check for $10,000.
Good job, brother.
ALEX (VOICEOVER):
This is pretty wild.
I came here to challenge
myself and put myself
through a super rigorous test.
And I came out on
top, and feels great.
This $10,000, I'm
actually gonna give
it all straight to my parents.
They supported me
through college as I
was learning bladesmithing.
And they're both
getting ready to retire,
so it's all going to them.